this is a production of cornell
university
really great thank you for joining and
today i'm going to be talking to you
about my thesis titled understanding the
role of cellular processes in grafted
plants
so in nature a process known as
inosculation occurs when the
a process known as inosculation occurs
in nature where different plants are
forced together either by pressure or
wounding and it leads to the fusion of
vascular or non-vascular tissue and it's
thought that this natural phenomenon may
have inspired early humans to begin
crafting
so grafting is an ancient process that's
been utilized for at least 2 000 years
originally to propagate woody crops that
were either difficult to grow from seed
did not grow true to seed like apples or
could not be rooted from cuttings
and today during my talk i'm going to
utilize a consistent terminology
and so the way that i refer to the
different parts of the graph tell us
where that piece came from originally so
the scion which is actually old french
for bud
is the ethical portion so the portion
that's being grafted on top and the
stock is the part that gives us the root
system and when i notate this it's going
to be scion colon stock so this will be
consistent throughout the whole talk
drafting is used for a lot of
economically important crops including
one of my favorite coffee
so here i'm showing you a coffee arabica
which is the desirable scion grafted
onto coffee conifero which is a
resistant root stock so grafting can be
used to confer abiotic and biotic
disease resistance like we see here
and more recently it's also used
in the propagation of herbaceous crops
so curcubits were the first that were
used in this way and um in a lot of east
asia almost all cucumbers are grafted to
pumpkin root stocks because it allows
them to be resistant to certain um you
know like fusarium wilt and other
diseases present in the soil
our lab uses tomato as our model system
this is because it has a great tool kit
of genetic resources including a
sequenced and well-annotated genome
multiple expression atlases and a
well-established transformation protocol
in addition to this it is also grafted
it is sold as a grafted crop
you can find it grafted onto many
different things including other tomato
varieties that help to boost yield and
some very fun kind of
novelty graphs like you see here so the
solanaceae family in general is often
intergrafted
and during grafting whether it's a woody
plant or an herbaceous plant it's going
to follow a conserved timeline of
physiological processes
this first starts with the initial
adhesion so this is when the cyan and
the stock touch each other and there's
going to be a secretion of different
sticky substances pectins and
polysaccharides that help the plant just
adhere to each other
next a layer known as the isolation
layer
shown here is this kind of little brown
line
which is just cellular debris that gets
kind of stuck there so that's visible
and we also start seeing the
proliferation of new callous cells the
callous cells are our undifferentiated
band-aid that helps to hold those two
pieces of tissue together
eventually we start to get enough
cellular differentiation there that the
scion and stock are cellularly connected
next we have the non-vascular cell
proliferation so meaning the pith cortex
epidermis that's going to start to
differentiate and we also get vascular
tissue differentiation
once we have enough
vascular tissue restored transport is
able to reoccur and the graft is fully
healed
and despite
a really long history of using grafting
we only under we only have a handful of
genes that we've been able to show are
directly related to grafting and these
genes fall into kind of these general
categories of that initial adhesion step
the non-vascular proliferation and
vascular proliferation
so i am specifically interested in graft
compatibility and anyone who has spent
any time with me in the last five years
has heard way too much about it so graph
compatibility is when two plants are
grafted together and the xylem and the
phoneme is able to reconnect this is in
contrast to immediate incompatibility
which is when you graph two things
together there's immediate death
but what's very interesting is something
called delayed incompatibility where you
can graft two things together and from
the surface it appears healed it might
even continue growing but months or even
years later the grafts will fail either
due to failed transport
or they'll break because they're just
not adhered to each other well sometimes
this is seen
you can actually tell like this very um
unhappy woody plant that's this is a
overproliferated callus likely due to
pooling of photosynthates or when the
bark is peeled back you'll see these um
these demarcations where the
xylem never heal
and there's a lot of different potential
causes for this um and some of the
hypotheses that are very abundant in the
literature include the effect of
phylogenetic distance
failed vascular reconnections and also
disrupted communication between the
scion and stock
so today i'm going to talk to you about
three chapters of my dissertation that
each address one of these potential
hypotheses starting with phylogeny and
this section is titled understanding the
taxonomic constraint insulin ac graft
compatibility building a graft
incompatible model system
so it's been historically noted for
thousands of years actually that more
closely related plants are more likely
to be compatible there's lots of
exceptions to this rule
but in general it's a good place to
start
so this means that when you're looking
at graph compatibility within a species
so different varieties that exist within
the same species are very likely to be
compatible such as
which is seen with apple
if you move up one layer to genus
there are certain
genera that are very compatible such as
prunus there are many different graft
compatibilities present within this
genus so those are inter-specific graft
compatibilities but there's also some
exceptions in there that aren't
compatible so it's not always true
and in our lab we've been able to show
that solanaceae
is has a lot of compatibility
intergenically between things like
petunia tobacco and then also these
intragenic
grafts like eggplant and potato
and recently there was this very
interesting paper that came out by
michitaka notaguchi
this was in science where they showed
that the presence of these beta 1 4
gluconases are essentially very sticky
substances present
in invinct allowed it to be compatible
to a really a wide variety of things
including closely related plants like
tomato and very distantly related plants
like arabidopsis which is seen here
and so i was interested if i could hone
in on some economically relevant crops
um and see within this group of solenoid
plants what the compatibility status was
so um for this experiment i looked at
capsicum anima or pepper fistulas
pubescence or ground cherry salina mica
persicum tomato or celino milogena
eggplant
and these were
a pretty appropriate group of plants to
test because not only do they have very
similar stature when we grafted them
meaning that they both have kind of long
thin hypocotyls but the width or the
diameter of the stem itself is very
similar so when these were grafted they
were all between 1.5 1.75 millimeters
and this is important because it
increases the chance that the cambium
and the vascular tissue are actually
going to line up with each other
so i grafted 16 different combinations
and i was actually able to get at least
one plant to survive in every single
graft
obviously there are some that perform
better than others for instance ground
cherry grafted onto eggplant was not
super happy to be around 30 days after
grafting
and when we look at each of these plants
so the x-axis here is showing you the
scion and the y-axis showing you the
stock here's all the 16 graph
combinations we're actually able to see
some signs of stress
including some signs of drought stress
including rolling leaves or a little bit
crunchy on the edges brittle stems so
very fragile or anthocyanin accumulation
which is a sign of stress in tomato
and the really our first line of action
whenever we're looking at graph
compatibility is to perform a bin test
and the bin test is an excellent test
because not only is it essentially free
it requires very little training and
it's relevant for grafting because
grafting often happens in the field so
this is something that breeders and
growers can actually test so when you
perform the bin test you're going to
hold the plant on either side of the
graft junction and just give it a little
gentle bend so this is a self-crafted
ground cherry nice and stable and the
graft junction is this wide part so it's
unable to break and actually the stem
above is weaker than the graft junction
similarly this is eggplant on tomato
and when i give that a little bend it
breaks up above the graph junction and
not at the junction itself whereas this
ground cherry pepper plant is uh quite
fragile and when you give it that the
bin test it's very clear that that graph
junction was really not held together
with anything
very strong
so we can look at um
the rate of break that occurred in all
of these different graphed combinations
so the self graphs are these first four
columns so they're very low
and then there's also two heterographs
that are very low so tomato eggplant and
eggplant tomato as well as all of the
salt grafts were very stable and unable
to be broken whereas all of the other
heterographs were actually very easy to
break
and when we when we do the bin test what
we're really doing is a proxy for how
much stability there is in the junction
and we know that the kind of support
beam of the plant is xylem so when it's
easy to break that's a good indication
that there is no xylem connecting those
two pieces so when we look at the
anatomy inside of these graph junctions
we can we can actually see this so the
green boxes here show which of these cut
graft combinations actually have a xylem
connection which i like to refer to as a
xylem bridge so xylem that's running
across
if we look up close this is a
self-crafted tomato so obviously very
compatible
and the dashed line is showing you the
graft
and this blue line is running right next
to the xylem so the xylem is very uh
bright white here very easy to pick out
and if we zoom in on this to make it
really clear you'll see that the xylem
cells that span the graph junction are
very cohesive they're very organized and
you can actually follow a single file of
cells all the way through so it's very
coordinated
and so we see this with all of the self
grafts as well as tomato and eggplant
whereas an incompatible graft so it
already looks a little different from
here
is going to have discontinuous vascular
tissue so we can show that the xylem
kind of gets approaches the graft
junction but they never meet each other
if we zoom in on that you can see that
the point where maybe you would hope
that the xylem connected is actually
full of undifferentiated cells so
there's some sort of miscommunication
that occurs that doesn't allow this
plant to connect its vascular tissue
and we see this with all of the other
heterographs so we can kind of see some
different things for pepper eggplant we
see an over proliferation of cells
in the ground cherry tomato i showed you
we have undifferentiated cells blocking
this or you can have
actually an air layer so there was never
contact and things just didn't heal
so we were able to show that tomato and
eggplant which are both members of
selena are intragenically graft
compatible and if you'll recall potato
is also compatible with tomato and
eggplant which is another member of
selena so selenium seems to be very
graft compatible
but all of the
other
genus that are in this experiment
were not compatible with each other so
capsicum physilis and selenium i was
unable to find any compatibility there
this is actually very exciting because
it allows us to
generate models to study incompatibility
and compatibility so as a compatible
model system we have eggplant and tomato
and as an incompatible model system we
have pepper and tomato
and so my research really asked
can i utilize this incompatible system
to better understand the genetic and
anatomical processes that occur in
compatible systems
so i'm going to use this system for the
rest of my talk to address different
questions so if you recall that when i
grafted all of these plants together
tomato and pepper kind of have a
moderate level of survival they don't
perform as badly as some others
but they're you know tomato pepper is
not happy
and it's especially interesting that you
can get kind of a diverse array of
phenotypes when you graft these plants
together so here you've got pepper
grafted on tomato and tomato grafted on
pepper and in the same exact batch of
grass with the same exact varieties you
can get plants that look like this so
there's a very interesting kind of
diversity that we see there
and so i wanted to see how consistent
this system was across varieties so i
tested four um habanero
doer delands cayenne and california
wonder these are plants from two
different species of pepper
and i chose habanero cayenne and
california wonder because they're
representatives of economically
important peppers and i chose door
delands because i have beef with this
paper
so 40 years ago this paper was published
and it actually lists door deland as a
compatible graph partner to tomato so i
was really interested to see if this
would hold up
so when i graft um these plants together
i'm able to track their survival over
time so i'll talk you through the colors
here the yellow line is self-crafted
tomato so that's the same for all of
them the green line is the self-grafted
pepper combination so they always
perform very nice very nice and the
heterographs are these purple and blue
lines so there is significant reduction
in survival in the heterographs of these
peppers
and then we come
to my pepper of interest steward delands
so this is a really interesting graft
combination so green line is
self-crafted pepper so this actually
pepperographs really poorly it has a
very low survival when it's grafted to
itself but interestingly it survives
pretty well when tomato is grafted on
top so i think that this is probably
what got people thinking that it was a
compatible craft so i needed to see if i
could break those peppers so i looked at
the um
tomato pepper heterographs gave them a
little bin test see what happened
broken so i think that they're just
really good at sticking together but it
doesn't seem like there's any vascular
connection there and for the peppers
that grafted very poorly they had very
poor survival
so this is self-crafted dura-delands
despite the fact that they survive at a
very low rate the junction itself is
very stable so this is likely just a
pepper that behaves a little bit
differently than the other ones but i
don't believe it to be compatible
and this is all of the other pepper
graft combinations i've generated this
nice little montage to show you that i
broke a lot of peppers for this graph
so i went through and i despite very
small stems or very fat stems
almost all of the heterographs were
easily broken
whereas the self graphs had a very
stable graph junction
and if we plot survival against the
percent that broke so survival is the y
axis and the percent that broke is the
x-axis we of course have door-to-lands
hanging out in the middle by itself so
kind of low survival but also low brake
all of the other self-crafts cluster up
here high survival low brake and all of
the heterographs have high break low
survival so this seems to be a pretty
stable trend with the exception of
georgia lands
and i wanted to see if you know we've
now said yes they can be broken or no
they can't i wanted to mathematically
quantify this so to do this we
collaborated with dr aaron sparks and
her phd who is now dr lindsey irwin at
the university of delaware to do
three-point bin tests the way that this
works is that a piece of tissue is
placed inside of an instron on two
fulcrum points and the third point is
the force probe so those are the three
points and here is
my tissue in there um and so as the
instrument pushes down it records the
force required to displace the tissue so
that's what this chart is showing you
this is the force displacement curve and
we're very interested in this elastic
measure
which is the amount of force required to
displace the stem prior to break there's
a few reasons we were interested in this
it's a good measure of kind of the
elasticity or the bendability of the
graph junction and it also can be
mathematically converted into the
bending modulus
the bending modulus is a unit of
measurement that allows us to record
force or tension um regardless of the
structural properties of what we're
comparing so you know tomato and pepper
are structurally dissimilar they have
different cellular composition and they
also have different size so by
converting this to the bending modulus
we're able to directly compare all of
these samples
and what we see is that we when we
exclude size from the equation there is
a significant difference between if a
plant is ungrafted self-crafted or
heterographed
and if we then look at each individual
sample we see that the heterographs are
significantly different than
self-grafted tomato
they're less but they're kind of similar
to self-grafted pepper
so we were able to show that there
actually is a reduction in the amount of
force required to bend the heterographs
and in some of these comparisons it's
very significant
again we had to look at the xylem
so here's a self-crafted tomato looks
beautiful
this is self-crafted cayenne looks very
similar to self-grafted tomato and in
the heterographs um the first picture
shows you a scion tomato the second
picture shows you uh tomato as the stock
so you'll see that there's
some disruption in the vascular tissue
you might see these over proliferated
callus bulges and the plants themselves
look pretty puny
so we see this with all of our tomato
pepper graft combinations
very likely to see callus over
proliferation and even adventitious
roots which is a symptom of graft
incompatibility so the scion is just
looking for water so they throw out
roots
like i mentioned the plants are very
different in size so this is
self-crafted tomato 30 days after
grafting and oh just in case you can't
see it there's tomato pepper uh 30 days
after grafting so really quite reduced i
quantified this as well so i measured
the area of the scion and the area of
the stock i was able to show that this
was super significant
depending on if it was a compatible or
incompatible graft the amount of growth
that occurred was very different this is
likely due to just reduced transport of
nutrients and water
i also measured the lateral growth that
occurs
so how much the stem was able to grow in
30 days this was also significantly
different depending on if it was
compatible or incompatible
so i've been able to show that across
all four of these graph combinations we
have consistent vascular disconnection
junction of
instability and reduced growth
so we're able to use this model to ask
other questions
so next we'll talk about vasculature
with this title
being gene regulatory networks for
compatible versus incompatible graphs
identify a role for walks for during
graft formation
so we don't know that much about what's
going on in the stem of a grafted plant
when it's redifferentiating the vascular
tissue but what we do know a lot about
is what happens in the root of
arabidopsis so this is a good place to
start and what you see here is that
there's a lot of signals that are
expressed in one cell and then act
non-cell autonomously in a different
place so that means that there's
movement and coordination that has to
occur
and we don't know if these signals are
moving apoplastically or simplistically
some of them we know some of them we
don't know so there's a lot of open
questions on how the vascular tissue is
formed especially in the stem
and i've showed you that self-grafted
plants heal the vascular tissue while
these heterographic plants don't
these hydrographic plants have a very
uncoordinated kind of discombobulated
xylem formation that implies some sort
of vascular
signaling breakdown so we wanted to see
when this happens
to do this we looked at grafted plants
three four five and six days after
grafting here i'm showing you
self-crafted tomato where the callus is
signified by little uh yellow arrows
newly formed proto-xylem is marked with
green arrows and the xylem bridge or the
continuous xylem strands are red
so in tomato we have lots of callus and
proto-xylem
by five days after grafting and by six
days after grafting we have continuous
xylem
in pepper we see something similar
albeit slightly delayed where we see a
callus and protozylene proliferation at
four five and six days after grafting
and not shown here is xylem connection
seven and eight days
whereas the heterographs have tons of
callus and protozoan proliferation but a
failure to achieve xylem bridges we see
that in both tomato pepper and pepper
tomato
so we were able to show that the tomato
pepper and pepper tomato vascular
dysregulation occurs in the first week
we wanted to see if we could understand
the genetic regulatory process that
underlie
what we see so we looked at self-crafted
tomato self-grafted pepper and the
heterograph at three time points that
represent important physiological steps
in graft formation so adhesion at one
day callus formation at three and
vascular differentiation at five
and before i talk about this i want to
give a huge shout out to our
collaborators at north carolina state
university dr lisa vandenbroe and dr
ross zazani who um not only built and
published the software that's used to
generate these networks but they were
also
very important collaborators and this
work wouldn't have been possible without
them
so the data i'm showing you here today
is the compatible graphs and if you're
very interested in the incompatible
graphs i'll talk just a little bit about
that in a minute so in the compatible
graphs we're able to use our
transcriptomic data to generate bayesian
networks so these are dynamic bayesian
networks which specifically is utilized
when you have temporal data so if we
kind of zoom in on what these uh center
parts so the big yellow dots are the hub
genes which are genes that are predicted
to regulate many downstream genes and
the color of the line coming off of them
tells you what day they're predicted to
act so green lines are one day blue
lines are three and red days are five so
there's actually a ton of information
just in these networks and i want to
talk to you all about it for an hour but
i don't have time
so if you would like to check out these
networks and shoot me an email i'm happy
to talk about these and the incompatible
networks are also in the paper so i
encourage you to go check those out as
well
so i'm going to show you a different way
to look at these self-grafted
hub genes so if we start in this middle
column
right here the gene ids that are listed
here are the hub genes if you move one
column to the left you have the
transcription factor family that that
gene belongs to and one column to the
left you have the graphed combination
that that hub came from if you return to
the middle one column to the right you
have the time point that is predicted to
act and one more column you have
different go terms that these genes fall
into and their predicted role in
grafting
so what's really interesting here is
that we expected that tomato and pepper
would have many orthologs of the same
genes functioning in this process but
what we actually found was that tomato
and pepper use in a lot of cases
completely distinct transcription factor
families during grafting so you'll see
all of these guys over here are only
attached to tomato and these guys down
here are largely only attached to pepper
so we were able to show that different
species can utilize completely distinct
genetic pathways to accomplish the same
goal which is grafting and at first this
was surprising but after i thought about
it it made a lot of sense because
grafting is not an evolutionarily
conserved process
it is humans taking advantage of plants
robust wound response and kind of
hijacking that for our intention so it
makes sense that plants would have very
diverse ways to handle wounding and then
it's not necessarily conserved in
specific genes
so i talked to you first about how
tomato and pepper heterographs have this
vascular disconnection phenotype and
then i showed you these networks and in
these hub genes if you have a chance to
look at them later you'll see that most
of these are actually not related to
vascular differentiation they're related
to non-vascular processes so why does
this happen
it kind of highlights a shortcoming of
bayesian networks which require the
genes in your data set to be highly
abundant in order to be represented as
hubs
and we think that the reason we don't
see vascular differentiation genes
highly abundant is because the cells
that are being differentiated make up
less than one percent of the graft
junction so here i'm showing you five
days after grafting and this newly
formed protozylum are highlighted in
that light pink color um and it's a
really small percentage of the tissue
that was actually ground and rna was
extracted from so in order to capture
this specific subset of genes we
returned back to arabidopsis and we
selected this subset of genes that are
involved in xylem cambo maintenance
we identified
orthologs and tomato and pepper
utilizing ortho finder and we wanted to
see if they were disrupted between the
self graphs which are down here and the
heterographs which are above it
and what you can't really see just by
looking is that every single one of
these genes is significantly disrupted
at at least one time point
so we put these genes into a regression
network
which is a little bit distinct from the
dynamic bayesian network because we're
utilizing one time point and utilizing
second time points to infer the
direction of it
and we were able to identify wax for as
a highly connected gene within this
network
and we are super grateful that dr zach
flippman at cold spring harbor was
willing to share a wax 4 mutant with us
and if you remember
there's wax 4 in arabidopsis it also has
a redundant earth log box 14 and tomato
wax 14 is not present so we expected
that because wax 4 is upstream of cambio
maintenance that there would be some
significant difference when we grafted
it
first we wanted to check out the mutants
because they hadn't really been analyzed
yet and we found that the waxford plant
was slightly smaller it had a reduced
leaf size and reduced root size
but that the vascular arrangement inside
of it so the xylem are these very large
kind of blue stained cells down here
they look pretty similar there's not any
like severe mutations or really strong
phenotypes so we were confident that
there wasn't anything largely wrong with
our plants going into grafting
the maybe most disappointing graph of my
phd was when i grafted these and they
all performed almost exactly the same
but luckily i knew that i could perform
a bin test on them and i showed that the
self-grafted walks for plants were very
fragile and easy to break whereas the
wild type plants were very strong so
despite there being no difference in
survival there was a huge difference in
the integrity of the junction itself
when we looked at the xylem in these we
found that self-grafted wild type as
well as the heterographs have beautiful
xylem bridges
nicely connected vasculature whereas the
self-grafted mutant has a very uh kind
of chaotic and disorganized uh graft
junction that kind of phenocopies what
we see in tomato and pepper
so we were able to show that wax 4 is
required in grafting in tomato but it
actually has no directionality so that
means it can be present in both sides of
the graph or it can be present in just
one and that's enough and there's lots
of open questions on walks four and i
think you'll see more of it from the
frank lab
so we're really excited to be able to
drop box four on to this figure
especially because it's the first gene
that was identified in an agronomically
grafted crop so it's very relevant
and have no fear these networks are
well underway in the frank lab to
identify new tools so um dr greg martin
had a pti 5 mutant that he was willing
to share with us and if you're super
interested in that
alice in our lab is going to be
presenting it as her honors thesis so
stay tuned for that email
attend to learn more
audrey woodmeyer
has been working tirelessly to help
generate these lateral boundary domain
mutants
and alice and audrey have worked
together to generate this f4 mutant
additionally
we're working on the genetic tools as
well so zach litman in addition to [ __ ]
sports shared the tomato ortholog of
cleve 41 42 and 44.
i've generated an expression fusion or
an expression gene and a fusion um line
and tomato so those will be exciting for
the future and brandon in our lab has
been working to generate pixie meetings
which we hope will have a very severe
phenotype
so more to come from that
and lastly i'm going to talk to you
about communication so this is an
exploration of tomato pepper's graph
junction isolation layer
so the graph junction
has kept me up at night for five years
and that is not because i dislike it but
because it is a very interesting
anatomical feature with this dynamic
intracellular communication and tissue
differentiation
and if you recall that in the process of
grafting this isolation layer formed so
this is debris that's just left over
from the process of grafting and over
time this debris is going to be uh
cleared from the graph junction getting
less and less and less until it's
finally gone and it's important that
this happens because we believe that
when the scion and the stock make that
first contact they have cellular contact
that's when mobile signals would be able
to be transmitted from scion to stock
and stock to scion
and we know that in grafted plants
secondary plasmodesmata can form at the
graph junction so it's likely that there
is some sort of mobile signals being
transmitted at this point
and if this isolation layer remains
there it could be a problem
so because these really gross dead
tissue layers are stuck in the graph
junction they could be a physical
barrier to the communication that's
required and because this persistent
death there is a symptom of
incompatibility i thought it could be a
potential cause
so margaret mentioned i came from a rat
lab i actually came from a rat
immunology lab so you're going to have a
crash course here
this is really kind of the inspiration
for why i've thought about this project
and it's because in animal systems when
a foreign tissue is introduced it's
going to give off antigens these
antigens are a signal of non-self that t
cells recognize transmit to b cells
which create memory in addition these
plasma cells are going to be putting out
antibodies that then tell the cell
itself what is this thing attack
and that's rejection so i was curious if
something similar to antigens might
exist in incompatible graphs
and this really got me thinking what
does it mean for a cell to die anyway so
i've got these three little cartoons of
cells so we've got a healthy cell with a
nice robust cell wall and we have cells
that are undergoing programmed cell
death and necrosis so they both have a
compromised cell wall but they have
different
appearance and different causes so the
difference in appearance is that
programmed cell death causes a shrinkage
of the plasma membrane while necrosis
can cause either no change or an
explosion of the plasma membrane so it
can swell up even within the cell wall
and the causes of these are different um
so it's hidden but it says moderate
stress so moderate stress can lead to a
signaling cascade some sort of
perception of that stress that then
leads to a genetically controlled
dna degradation process whereas necrosis
is caused by an acute stress or
something so significant or abrupt that
the plant cell has no ability to respond
to this and it leads to uncontrolled
cell death and these two types of death
can be
used as proxies to ask other questions
which is is there intercellular
communication that cop between the cyan
and the stock that leads to that cell
death
or is this stress induced death which i
have related to during my phd
but
so i wanted to ask is there a
compatibility signal that cells use to
perceive self or use to perceive
non-self
so to do this i first needed to figure
out what was dead in my grapp junctions
so i used a viability stain called
trypan blue that can enter into cells
with compromised cell walls so
regardless if it's undergoing program
cell death or necrosis the cell is able
to enter it
and to do this
my wonderful undergrad alice and i
looked at ungrafted self-grafted and
heterographic plants at 7 14 and 21 days
after grafting here they all are
and tripant blue is really interesting
because originally it was used in kind
of like single celled organisms or cell
cultures and in that instance it's very
black and white it either stains
something blue or purple or it doesn't
viable not viable but in plants which
are these you know multicellular deep
tissue organs you're going to have a
spectrum of stain you're going to have
regions that are this kind of almost
light blue
white color or you have very little cell
death or you have regions that will
stain back almost black and this is
because there's many many layers of
cells that are non-viable so it looks
black
and we have a similar spectrum um in in
my work so i modified this protocol
slightly so mine comes back a little bit
more purple than blue but that's okay so
areas that are containing very low
levels of cell death stain this kind of
light pink color and areas that contain
what i'm calling deep tissue cell death
are this almost black purple color so at
seven days after grafting ungrafted
tomato and pepper obviously have very
low levels of cell death whereas all of
the graft combinations have these very
deep
cell death pockets right at the graph
junction and i'm pointing those with
little yellow arrows
by 14 days after grafting the cell death
has reduced in the self graphs but it's
kind of hanging out in those
heterographs and 21 days after grafting
it is pretty much gone from self crafts
but still very present in those
heterographs
and if we look at this as a percentage
of the area of the graph junction itself
we can track it over time
so as we move through time
the percentage of cell death in the
self-grafted plants reduces
and despite the fact that these pie
charts look identical they are not i
swear
the amount of cell death present in the
heterographs is extremely consistent so
this is a persistence of cell death in
the graph junction of the heterograph
over time
so now i know that there is cell death
in the junction but i want to see what's
causing it
is it inter intercellular communication
or is it stress
so to do this i utilized an assay um
called a tunnel assay and it's called
that because its real name is the
terminal dioxin neutral title
transferased udp nikon labeling assay so
tunnel's a better name and the way that
this works is that the tdt enzyme can
recognize double-stranded breaks present
in dna these double-stranded breaks are
really a hallmark of endonuclease
cleavage which is the way that
program cell death occurs these
endonucleases cut up the dna and the tdt
identifies the free hydroxy group and
adds this super stable
dutp with the fluorescent probe stuck to
it
so then when we image these under the
confocal only cells undergoing
programmed cell death are going to be
tagged with this fluorescent um
chlorophore despite the fact that the
cells undergoing necrosis are also dying
so we're able to differentiate between
any cell and programs held back
an undergraduate who graduated from our
lab last year ali hermansen
really
optimized this protocol so she did a
great job and what i'm showing you on
the bottom is just a little slice of a
pepper stem that i've treated with dnase
one to kind of mimic what a over
you know high level of those double
stranded breaks would look like
and in my work i also counter stained
all of this with propidium iodine so
that we could orient ourself inside of
the tissue
but for the rest of my slides i'm not
going to show the propidium iodine just
for time you'll have to believe me when
i say that we are in fact in the graph
junction
so here are ungrafted stems at 7 14 and
21 days after grafting
so these really bright strands that you
see are autofluorescents coming off of
the xylem so they can be kind of
distracting when you're trying to look
at these so it's like looking at stars
in the night sky look at the black part
of the sky and the stars will become
more visible so if you look over on
these sides you'll start to see these
little puncta that are scattered
randomly without within the cell and
those are that's just the normal low
level of program cell death that's
occurring
probably not actually in the natural
state but of a plant that's just been
chopped in half so that's that's what we
see
at
the self-grafted plants we at seven days
see kind of a low
normal-ish level amount of programmed
cell death at the graph junction but by
14 and 21 days after grafting program
cell death is starting to be elevated in
the tissue surrounding the graft so not
just
in the periphery but also near the
vascular tissue and i'm going to show
you a zoom up in a minute
and in heterographic plants we see the
same thing we see an elevated level of
programmed cell death in the graph
junction as early as seven days
so here's a zoomed up version of what
you're seeing in those little pictures
these little puncta are cells undergoing
program cell death and what we found is
that this elevated rate of program cell
death is present in all grafted plants
it's not specific to if the plant is
incompatible so it's likely that program
cell death plays some role in the
process and i've kind of hypothesized
that it has to do with the transition of
all of this callus differentiating into
you know whatever type of cell type it
needs to be and there's a little bit of
cell culture work to back that up
that looks good um so
deep tissue cell death does not overlap
with the uh programmed cell death
present in the graph junction so the
program cell that is present not only in
the callus on the edges but also in the
tissue near the vasculature
this is not what we see in the deep
tissue cell death where these areas of
death are very
very consistent on the outside
so the
death that we see in tomato pepper grass
is not
due to programmed cell death despite the
fact that program cell death is
occurring in the graft it is necrosis so
that means that some acute stress is
acting upon those areas of deep tissue
cell death causing uncontrolled cell
death
and leading to stress-induced death so
the you know kind of outlying question
is what is the stress so there's some
different hypotheses here and i have my
favorites but um it could be metabolic
toxicity it could be a cytotoxic
accumulation of ross it could even be
osmotic stress any of these are things
that can cause stress-induced necrosis
and so you know at the end of all of
this i can say that i've generated a lot
of knowledge about graft incompatibility
in each of these hypotheses so under
phylogeny i was able to show that there
are many intergenic incompatible graphs
in the solenoid and most importantly
that survival does not equal
compatibility
also i showed that eggmado and petmato
are ideal systems to study graft
compatibility related questions
under vasculature i was able to show
that tomato and pepper utilize distinct
genetic pathways to grafts
that incompatible grafts have perturbed
gene expression and that wax for is
required for grafting and tomato and
then under communication i was able to
show that incompatible grafts have
persistent cell death
that programmed cell death is
upregulated in all types of grafting and
that the tomato pepper junction cell
death is due to acute stress-induced
necrosis
so next i need to thank some people um
obviously i need to thank the frank lab
which when i joined was just three
people
it was really fun to watch us grow she's
a nice big group now and even my
favorite member of the lab gwynevere it
was fun to watch her also grow up and
she doesn't even look like this anymore
she's so big
also a big shout out to margaret um so
if you don't know margaret runs her
whole organism is running off of gimme
coffee and candy at any given time
that's all that's in her system so i
hope that after i've graduated you can
improve your pre-workout snacks a little
bit
i think things can get better
i also want to say thank you to all of
the research mentors i've had before
this point
so down in the bottom left is dr neil
snow i think he's in the call somewhere
and dr virginia ryder who are my
undergraduate mentors
blake myers and his postdoc tc
and also the vanek lab here we are as
gfp the nerdiest halloween
costume i also need to thank all of my
friends who are really important during
grad school it's good to have a support
system um these people from they're all
over the world not everyone is here but
i'm really grateful they've had their
support
also my family both those that i was
born with those that i married into um
you've all been just like a backbone a
pillar always asking me how i'm doing
jio the whole time i've been studying so
it's been great
and then to leo who i forced to eat a
lot of cheese
dress up as stupid halloween costumes
and live through 400 inches of snow um
so thank you for always following me to
crazy places and doing strange things
with me
and lastly you guys knew it was coming
a huge thank you to my fur babies tater
tot and sebastian
especially during quarantine when i was
trapped in my house it was so important
to have them there
and lastly there's a few other people i
want to just specifically um think
because they were very integral to my
work so um alice brevorgian right here
the best undergrad
ali hermansen who graduated last year my
lab in-laws in the vitamin u lab who
have let me steal probably more coffee
than i want to think about
my committee members elena eric and
joyce the collaborators who were
directly involved in the data i've
showed you today
the staff at cornell including
greenhouse and growth chamber staff the
plant transformation staff and the
imaging facility
all of you are really the backbone of
the research that's done here at cornell
and i hope you you know that and get a
lot of thank you
and
my usda pre-doctoral fellowship which
was a great
thing to receive and to be able to focus
on my research
and to to travel and do things with that
so with that i'm happy to take any
questions
any questions
yeah
thanks so much for the thoughts and
congrats um i was just wondering you
generated some new regulatory networks
did you happen to see any
other um i'm thinking of non-coding rnas
that popped out that helped regulate
that um tissue specific or soft specific
grafting success so the question was if
in my networks i identified any
non-coding
rnas and if those were involved in
anything
so one of the assumptions you have to
make when you're doing gene regulatory
networks at least in bayesian inference
is that you have to be able to
make the assumption that each gene is
acting on the next gene and so a really
safe bet is to include transcription
factors only in that in that original
setup of your genes and the reason why
this is important is because bayesian
networks become less accurate the more
genes that are present so you have to
make some cuts
to keep the gene size small so
unfortunately we weren't able to do that
in our analyses but i mean the data is
is there we have the
rna seq data so if you'd like to
collaborate i think hit margaret up
here
let me
see nope
just go hannah
um what are the biggest cases of graft
incompatibility within the industry yeah
this is a great question because
grafting is
economically relevant um i think that
some of the most probably economically
important cases of graft and
compatibility are happening within stone
fruit so there's lots of inter grafting
that occurs between pears and apples and
between plums and peaches and not all of
those are compatible and in really
confusing instances sometimes they're
only compatible in one direction like
plum has to be the scion and peach has
to be the stock for it to work and
things like that so that's probably one
of the most broadly important but i
think it's it's more common that graft
incompatibility occurs in like
ornamental trees and actually if you
walk around on campus at cornell you can
find some that are incompatible um and
oftentimes
people will just sell those because they
look good ornamentally for a while and
then eventually they'll break so i think
it's more common in ornamental actually
yes definitely ask questions um
sure um it's just kind of like a
hypothetical question you don't have to
have an answer but if you were able to
to
like
tamp down whatever acute stress you
think is causing the cell death do you
think that would then make them
compatible like incompatible grass
compatible or do you think that all of
that cell death is like a side effect of
the acute stress and like the stress is
causing another thing it causes yes so
the question was if we could reduce the
stress that causes cell death could we
overcome graft incompatibility i think
in tomato pepper the answer is no
because i think that there's two
two things happening you have disrupted
vascular
um kind of a you know organization
that's occurring it's possible that the
signal we're looking for is being
blocked by the cell death but it's also
possible that there's something else
going on there like it could be a dosage
thing or it could be divergence of you
know receptors or ligand but we won't
know that until we're able to figure out
exactly what the stress is and see if we
can reduce that stress and then see what
happens so there's there's a few more
experiments we need to know
we'll know for sure
let's see so someone asked do you know
if there's any effect of the geometry of
the contact to flat surfaces versus a
groove yes this is a really good
question
so something that happens when you graft
is that there's an initial dry down
period so the tissue pulls back slightly
and each tissue pulls back differently
so tomato stays pretty pretty
cylindrical whereas pepper has a really
intense dry bath so ways that we
overcome this is that instead of
performing a flat graft we perform a
super steep
slant graft so that despite the pullback
the central portion of the stem is still
in direct contact so we've been able to
overcome that but there is a whole area
of you know very horticultural graft
work that has to do with optimizing the
specific shape of the graft to improve
graft success so i won't say that i'm an
expert in that but
i think we've overcome that
um commercial tomato rootstocks have
complex genetics how do they end up
having such wide graft compatibility
yeah this is a really good question so
if you have very diverged plants how are
they able to graft and so this is one of
those
exceptions so you know thousands of
years ago ancient greek philosophers
were writing about how plants that are
closely related are
going to be able to graft and they were
like very black and white in that and
plants that are distantly related won't
but we know that that's not the case um
so whatever it is that the plants are
recognizing in each other or maybe it's
a lack of recognition in those very
distant graphs whatever that is it's not
necessarily tied to how closely related
they are it could be tied to how much
evolutionary time has passed between two
things you know like maybe something has
diverged in one species that has not
diverged in another and because we don't
know exactly what we're looking for yet
we're unable to really answer that
question well but i've thought about it
a lot
yeah sure so with uh the incompatible
graph it seems very interesting because
they can grow for quite a bit of time
until they break so is is breaking the
only
symptom because i'm thinking about like
the trees around campus you're talking
about like could would you see
differences in like transpiration or is
manually going in and trying to break a
deal yes so the question was in
incompatible graphs you know kind of is
there anything else that happens besides
breakage um so there is some work where
they've done nutrient profiling in the
scion as well as checked trigger
pressure using pressure bombs and things
like that which i dabbled in but i
didn't show you the data
and in the scion when you have poor
vascular connection you have
significantly reduced nutrient transport
and this hasn't been tested in
everything
but in that can lead to things like
blossom and rot and
issues with yield because you have low
transport
and i would say that probably in the
next 50 years all of these incompatible
trees we see on campus will break during
a storm
so they they will have some sort of
wind or what anything that stresses it
and it will break and this is a really
big problem for growers because the
grafting is expensive when it comes to
you know farming because you have to
train someone to go out and graft either
bench grafting or field grafting and
it's a really high
economic and time input with the
expectation that that plant will grow
fruit for maybe 50 years and if it
breaks in four you know as a tomato
something growing for four years seems
like oh that's great but as a tree if it
only grows for four years that was a
failure
so it is we're using a herbaceous model
but you have to think about that in the
woody grafted world it's a very
different process let me read carefully
so they're asking um there's a lot of
similarity between the networks and
opposition genetics
and grasses could be simpler to try to
take a more mechanistic approach in
terms of thinking the life history of
cells and graph sites the genes that
regulate these and if this could cluster
into a suite of maybe two or three more
or less optimal strategies
yeah i'll have to think about that
i think that
yeah i think i'll have to think about
that one and i know john that we follow
each other on twitter so i'll probably
reach out to you after i've had a chance
to to ponder that and let you know what
i think because i haven't thought about
the overlap between obsession at all
yeah
do you know where vox 4 is expressed
like the south chart
yes so the question is do we know where
walks 4 is expressed um
kind of
so we know where vox 4 is expressed in
tomato
but not where it's necessarily expressed
in the graft junction so there is
always a kind of assumption we make that
things are going to be present in
vascular differentiation of the stem as
they are in the root or you know walks
forward is identified in tomato by the
scanlan lab so
thanks for that
um so we do we don't know that yet but i
think in the works is that we'd like to
have a reporter line or we've even had
reviewers ask for in c2s which we
politely declined doing
for our publication but we'd like to see
exactly where they're being expressed
and also if they're mobile because i
have a lot of interest in that
and seeing how what the dynamics are
works for in the graph junction itself
i just wanted to add to that so in the
class that everybody left to go we were
writing a paper today about
um tomatoes and these they were
localizing walks for in tomatoes and
they found it in like the flu what they
call the flow and parenchyma or the
fibers
but i actually thought they looked like
more virus cycle and i understood
actually the walks for
um to be more related to cambium
maintenance actually instead of actual
like differentiation of the cells
yeah
so
the question was um there was a recent
paper paper where they showed that wax 4
was
possibly in the para cycle is that what
you were
thinking
okay so it's in a non-vascular tissue
associated with the vascular
system um it's interesting you ask that
question because i actually just
yesterday was really thinking about the
paracycle and tomato as one does and
some of the papers i was coming across
people were making the argument that the
pericycle should be considered
meristematic tissue because of its
ability to produce adventitious roots
so it's possible that in tomato it
functions slightly different than what
we're
expecting um but i we also
you know say knowing that it's in the
paracycle is very exciting because one
of the other graft related genes al4
aberrant lateral formation 4 directly
related to paracycle maintenance after
grafting so you know i'm not sure
exactly what it's doing in the graph
junction but i'm happy to know it's at
least associated with the vasculature
and possibly associated with the tissue
that some consider to be meristematic so
that's all that's all good in tracks and
i'm excited to see
see where we actually can find it
okay
yeah i think i hopefully if other people
had questions um online that i didn't
get to please shoot me an email or a
twitter message i'm happy to talk
awesome
thank you for that wonderful
presentation
um
and
later today we'll be on the second floor
of plant science in a graduated cylinder
thank you so much it was great thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu